hello everyone and welcome to today's
keynote presentation titled membrane
cytoskeletal dynamics in disease this
webinar is part of the cell bio 2021 and
i'm susie valdez of labyrinth and i will
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots so let's get
started before we begin i want to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
and we encourage you to participate by
communicating with other attendees using
our new live chat feature during the
presentation you can find this live chat
located at the right of your screen
you can also participate by submitting
as many questions as you want during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
send we'll answer as many questions as
we have time for at the end of the
presentation
now if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation please click
on the help desk located at the
bottom of your screen within the
navigation bar or from the lobby now as
a reminder this presentation is
educational and offers free continuing
education credits click on the
continuing education credits link
located in the abstract window below the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain those credits
without further ado i now present
today's keynote speaker dr mark mcniven
a george m eisenberg professor of
biochemistry and molecular biology and
the director of the mayo center for
biomedical discovery for complete
biography of our speaker please visit
the biography tab at the left of your
screen dr mike nevin welcome you may now
begin your presentation sir
okay well thank you all for having me um
i appreciate the honor of of uh being
able to talk to you today
and uh
the talk
uh we'll have three parts
that's focused on the role of membrane
dynamics in the cytoskeleton
in metastatic invasion
in cancer
fatty liver
and
how some of these dynamics can regulate
mitochondrial genomic stability which
also has a disease relevance
before i start i know it's it's been a
long
year and a half for all of us
and
i look look forward to you know being
meeting you in person at some time i was
i was just telling uh the group that
i've just had three meetings canceled uh
in the last uh 24 hours so things are
still pretty locked down as far as our
business goes
but i appreciate you attending this and
i look forward to any questions you
might have
so
um
[Music]
let's see
i wanted to start out with the
metastatic invasion
portion
and uh
i'm
understand that my cursor you don't see
my cursor so i don't really have a
pointer and so i'll have to maybe take a
little extra time to guide you through
slides
rather than doing it visually with a
pointer so i hope that works out okay
and uh this work was uh spearheaded by
three people in the lab student kevin
burton
and two long time colleagues uh hong
kong and gina razidla
and
essentially um
we're interested in metastatic invasion
because it's important if you look at
the cartoon on the left
you can see the the central problem of a
primary tumor
that will disseminate and migrate away
and invade into a blood vessel and
get transported to distal sites distal
organs
and and uh and grow there and of course
if we could prevent this uh the surgeons
could cut out the tumors and throw them
away the problem is that they spread
throughout our body
and a short video clip of some
pancreatic ducular adenocarcinoma cells
that we have in the lab in a chamber
that all play here
in which uh you can see after we add
some epidermal growth factor the cells
will migrate
uh from the right towards the left
and and fill the chamber
so this happens over 12 hours but you
can imagine
with this motogenic response
that over uh days and weeks and years
that uh these tumors could could
progress and migrate to distant sites
and we're also interested in
understanding how
not only how they migrate but how they
uh they
degrade matrix and remodel their stroma
and so
this video that i'm showing you here is
an example of one of the processes that
we're interested in of a pancreatic
tumor cell that's expressing uh
our rfp tagged
metalloprotease
and we can put this cell on a green
fluorescent substrate and then ask the
cell to move
and it does that spontaneously
and you can see as the cell migrates
from uh
one o'clock down to seven o'clock
it's degrading the matrix and leaving
this black
uh
void
on the coverslip as it moves along of
course it's on a coverslip it can't go
through the glass
but if it could um it would penetrate
down into the z-axis
and go into a blood vessel and
um
this is
depicted in this video here
in which we've plated some
uh pancreatic tumor cells that we we've
pseudo-colored colored in red
on top of a porous filter
and
a lot of people at study invasion use
these filters they're called transwell
migration chambers
and you put a uh growth factor down at
the bottom and ask the cell to to
migrate through and you can coat the
cell with gelatin
and i
prevent it from migrating through unless
it actively secretes proteases
like in the previous video that i showed
you and so
what we'll do is that we'll show you
kind of a three-dimensional rendering of
this as we'll look at the bottom
and and so you can see
uh that we're rotating and uh the
computer puts together the z-stacks and
now we're looking at the underneath
and you can see that the cell has
extended these tendrils
or lamella lamellapods through the
bottom
uh as it's progressing through
so these are the kinds of things that
uh
we're interested in we think about a lot
and we think are important to the field
of really pretty much all different
types of cancers
and so what are some of the molecular
components what's the machinery that
drives this
well we study two proteins called
dynamin and actinin
which are cytoskeletal uh proteins one
structural and one's in gtpase and i'll
tell you a little bit more about them in
a second
and we've published papers actually
almost 20 years ago that link the actin
cytoskeleton with this large gtpase
dynamic
and
published a paper
in neurochemistry
10 years ago
showing that in growth cones
that from neurons that migrate along
[Music]
you can see that there is a
accumulation of dynamic
out in the growth cone
that co-localizes significantly with
this actin structural protein called
actinin one
and so
this co-localization suggests that the
two proteins interact and might
somehow support the migration of growth
cones during development
a similar structure are these
lamellapods and i just touched on those
in the previous slide showing you
lamellapods of tumor cells that are
protruding down through
the porous filter
and we kind of view lamellapods as the
structural equivalent
from a tumor cell to a growth cone
of a neuron
and again if we look at
uh the two proteins act 10 and 1 and
dynamin 2 in this lamellapod you can see
a pretty
convincing co-localization
and so we thought that it would be
important to understand how these
proteins might interact together
and support tumor cell migration
to tell you a little bit more about
these proteins
so you care about them dynamin ii is a
mechanoenzyme
and it's involved in membrane incision
regulation of the actin cytoskeleton
which implicates it in migration and
invasion and so some of you might know
this protein and it's well characterized
to form
polymer polymeric rings that go along
membrane invaginations interact with the
cytoskeleton and pinch off membranes
from the cell surface
in contrast
actin is our actinin is an actin
bundling protein
there's four types the non-muscle form
in uh tumor cells or actinin one and
four and has also been implicated in
migration and invasion
what made this particularly interesting
to us is that upon histological
examination
we can see that dynamic two
uh that we published in aqua gene back
in 2012
you can see that if you compare the
dynamin ii staining in tumors versus
normal tissue that there's a significant
enrichment of this large gtpase
in the active tumors implicating it
perhaps in invasive migration
also if you look at the right the
actinin protein f10 and iv
is also markedly upregulated in
the the ducts of this pancreatic cancer
so the combination of
the expression
the distribution the co-localization
made us think that these could
contribute and work together towards
supporting tumor invasion
and indeed if we take tumor cells
and express
these proteins you can see that it
enhances their motility so we asked if
co-expression of dyne2 and act 10 and 4
might promote an invasive phenotype
if we just express gfp
into one of these tumor cells
and hopefully this is playing for you
you can see
that
the cell is kind of just sitting there
undergoing some oscillations maybe send
out a small pseudopod
but let's compare that to cells that we
overexpress both actinin 4 and dynamic 2
together and see if that
changes their motility
so let's look at this cell expressing
both proteins
and
while the cell
without any kind of
chemochemical gradient doesn't really
migrate
you can see how much more pliable and
dynamic the so is
sending out these weird structures and
then constricting almost kind of
breaking in half
let's look at this cell over here which
is also crazy dynamic
moves
pinches
it's not a productive productive
motility but it clearly is dynamic
so this kind of supports that
these two proteins uh contribute
to cell dynamics
so we asked biochemically
if these two proteins might interact and
did kind of standard biochemical assays
um
using in vitro pull down assays to see
if they might interact and you can see
that
at 10 1 gst will interact with with
dynamin 2. again i can't point to these
things to help you along
but i'll just describe them
so in order to see if
we could disrupt this interaction in
living cells it was important to
uh map the interaction sites and so the
cartoon at the upper right
shows you the different domains of the
actinins and of the dynamins
and after a considerable amount of
molecular mapping
we found that
the interaction sites uh for actinin and
for dynamin both
uh were loc uh situated at the very c
termini of each protein you can see with
the little red areas there that if we
cut off those regions
the proteins would no longer interact
so this enabled us to then perform
knock-down experiments in the tumor
cells and then re-express either
wild-type or
deletion mutant proteins and see if that
has an effect on
different criteria
these domains happen to represent the
very c terminal about 28 to 31 amino
acids
and so what are the criteria we're going
to use with these mutants
we're going to test three invasive
parameters
cellular 2d migration
uh which you saw in the very first movie
stromal remodeling and trans well
migration which i gave you examples of
in the subsequent mode
so
let's go ahead and express actinin 4 and
dynamine cells
and then trace their pathways
on a two-dimensional glass slide and see
how they're altered so we look at
actinin
and there's four
diagrams there in which we use image j
software to map and trace
the distribution of the cells over time
and
you can see that in the upper left
the non-targeted knockdowns the cells
are moving around there's long swivel
lines each squiggle line represents a
cell moving
but if we look down at the
upper right there's less movement when
we knock down actinin
we can rescue it
when we
express wild-type actinin for
but not
when we express
the c-terminal deletion that prevents it
from interacting with dynamic
and then this is quantitative in the bar
graph down below
we can do the reciprocal experiment
of expressing or knocking down dynamic
two
you can see that under c there the
non-targeted sis the cells are moving
along pretty well
we knock down dynamin
we attenuate the movement and we can't
rescue that with the c-terminal
truncation of dynamin
so
this suggested that this structural
interaction between the two proteins is
a functional one and contributing to
migration
our next parameter was
invadopodial matrix degradation
and
tumor cells extend these tendrils down
into the matrix
that will secrete metalloproteases as i
was telling you before
and if we look at
cells stain for
uh actinin or actin you can see these
invadopodia as these pump tape spots
that go around the cell
and if we knock down
uh actinin
and compare how much gelatin degradation
that's at the bottom
of the uh
the images there
you can see like that movie i showed you
before
that there are a series of punctate
invasive spots
in which the proteases have degraded the
matrix leaving the dark circles
but
the knockdown of the dynamine or the of
the actinin iv
and trying to rescue it or the mutant
didn't work
and then
we quantitated these with the act 10 and
4 mutant rescues or the dynament ii
mutant rescues you can see in the bar
graphs on the right
showing that
the wild type could rescue degradation
but
the mutants were only about 20 percent
uh active as far as matrix remodeling
suggesting that again this cytoskeletal
interaction with motility innovation
appears to be important and finally
as i showed you in that 3d rendering of
cells that were migrating and protruding
down through a filter
we asked if this interaction is key for
invasive migration through transwell
assays
and so what you're seeing on in the
color micrographs in g there
is a tumor cell
looking at it in the z-axis from the
side sending its tendrils down through
the migration filter
but then with the delta c
mutation of actin and you can see that
the cells are really up on top and not
protruding through
and so we can look at the bottom of
these filters again expressing
after the knockdown gfp wild-type
proteins or truncated proteins and you
can see that
there's there's just not much of a
rescue with the mutant compared to the
wild type
so why do we think this is important
we think that they're both upregulated
we know they're both upregulated in
human pancreatic cancers
they interact directly to promote
invasive cell migration
via actin cytoskeletal remodeling
and this appears to be specific for act
10 and 4
not act 10 and 1
which is interesting because they're
both expressed
in the cells they're very similar
proteins but one uh
interacts with dynamic in this capacity
i should say accident iv does while the
other does not
we just recently published a paper this
year though that implicates actinin1
in macropinocytic uptake
taking up nutrition from the external
environment that's used to feed these
tumor cells to do their invasive
tasks
and it appears
that this actinin 1
actually is on macropinosomes not only
helping them internalize
but help them form actin tails and
comets
which we showed that dynamin was capable
of doing
back uh almost 20 years ago
so while one form appears to be involved
in migratory invasion
this form actinin1 appears to interact
with dynamin at
the cell surface
and on internalized macropinosomes
to internalize nutrition to feed the
tumor cells
and how the dynamic might discriminate
between
uh the two types of actinin and how the
actinin knows to go
to uh or type one go to macrophineosomes
while type 4
goes to invadopodia is something that
we're trying to figure out
so
these cytoskeletal elements while
involved in metastatic invasion turns
out
really do a lot of different things the
cell doesn't necessarily invent
new proteins to do different tasks it
utilizes its machinery to perform
distinct tasks
and one of the things
that we are interested in
is
we study both the liver
and the pancreas our lab is in a
division of gi at the mayo clinic and
this group
of two post-docs ryan micah and two
senior tech's colleagues eugene and sean
were interested in how this membrane
cytoskeletal machinery might participate
in hepatic diseases
and what do we think about in this
regard
well we're an obese society i think i
just heard on the radio this morning
that we're actually more obese as a
country
today than we thought we were um based
on the statistics five years ago
about uh 40 to 50 percent of us are
considered clinically obese
and this is due to historical insights
if you look at this
quote
at the top here
that i found
from
a military governor of southern
california in the 1840s
and he wrote
when the native population the native
americans
they were corralling them and
restricting them to u.s army
barracks's and provisions
they said that
the natives became lethargic overweight
and healthy and actually many of them
died
and so
you had
three million years of evolution of
human beings
coming out of africa based on a hunting
and gathering metabolism and then
suddenly in the last 50 years
particularly with the advent of high
fructose corn syrup that was put in
pretty much all our foods in the 1970s
you end up with
an obese population we're not programmed
or designed
to burn off all these sugars
particularly as we come we become more
sedentary
and so the end result in this center
picture
is a picture of a fatty liver
and matching our obesity rates 40 to 50
percent of us have fatty liver
which looks pretty gross here in the
picture
if you do a histological section of
liver
below it in the pink
you can see that the distinct organelle
of this disease
is the lipid droplet
and it was thought for the longest time
that the lipid droplet is just
essentially this these blobs of fat
hydrophobic triglycerides floating in an
aqueous environment of the cytoplasm but
actually these lipid droplets are
complex organelles there's about a
hundred different proteins associated
with their phospholipid monolayer
making them dynamic
they grow they shrink
depending on the needs of the of the
cell and the organism
and so we're very interested in trying
to understand these lipid droplets and
how the hepatocyte the central liver
cell
catabolizes these droplets
and so on the right is an electron
micrograph
of a lipid droplet
which you see in white and it's actually
engulfed by an autophagolysosome
so a degradative structure in the cell
that you can see has engulfed it and
will catabolize and break it down with
its phospho or acid lycases
and also of note is you can see that
there's a mitochondria that is in
intimately associated with this
lipophagic synapse as we call it
and so
the cell has this structure and
functional relationship right there of
an energy source the lipid droplet
encased by a degradative organelle and
the organelle that's going to utilize
those degraded lipids is right there the
mitochondria
and so
it wasn't always thought that lipophagy
or the process of degrading lipids
was important in the hepatocyte but when
we look at images like this that we took
in the lab
and you can see that
there is a low mag of a hepatocyte on
the left and the right
the blue is the nucleus the lipid
droplets are in red and the lysosomes
are in green
and
while there is some contact of the the
lysosomes around the lipid droplets and
dmso treated cells
if we treat the cell with an acid lipase
inhibitor
called lylostat
for
overnight or for a day
you can see that almost all the lipid
droplets end up being
internalized within the lysosome
because the lysosome can't degrade them
it provides a block so anything that
gets in there doesn't get degraded and
you can see how intimate this
association is so these are the things
that we're interested in trying to
understand how the liver cell degrades
these
and
what we saw
upon electron microscopic examination
was that there appeared to be a size
based subpopulation
suggesting that there were different
catabolic processes
if we look on the left
there's large lipid droplets
on the right very small ones and those
are internalized
inside of a lysosome so you can see with
the red pointing to the little lipid
droplets and the yellow arrows pointing
to the lysosomes and we did statistics
on these and indeed were convinced that
large lipid droplets just
were not getting within the lysosomes
probably because of size based exclusion
so
micah schott and sean weller in the lab
tested the hypothesis that lipolysis
using soluble lipases in the cytoplasm
and lipophagy with the action of
a lipophagic organelle works
sequentially to target large and small
lipid droplets for catabolism
i won't go through the data because it
actually
uh took a long time to figure this out
and it kind of sets the stage for what
i'll show you in the next couple of
slides
but this cartoon should summarize it
in that you have this large lipid
droplet
and in the left you can see there's a
atgl or a dip a dipocyte triglyceride
lipase
and
it will actually work on the lipid
droplet to shrink it
because the autophagic membrane
the curvature of the lipid droplet is
just too
too broad for the autophagic membrane to
encompass it so
you can see
the the autophagosome can't form
and the lipase works on the lipid rocket
to shrink it down to a size
that then the autophagosome can bind and
encompass it
allow the lysosome to dock to the
autophagosome and then you get the
degradation of the final component of
the lipid droplet
so
lipolysis appears to precede lipophagy
but what kind of lipophagy is this
why do we ask that question
well when we do electron microscopy on
the hepatocyte
as i mentioned we saw small lipid
droplets recite residing within
lysosomes and late endosomes that you
can see here in the blue arrows
the thing that we noticed was that the
lysosomes
and uh or the the structures with
which the lipid droplets reside are
single membrane
suggesting this is not a conventional
canonical autophagic structure
off to the right there you can see in
the same cell i think
we're able to see
mitophagic
structures of conventional autophagy or
mitophagy in this case
and you can see that there's a double
membrane around the mitochondria
not so for the lipophagy
so
we asked how this interaction might
occur
and
so
schultz in the lab
made
some some very nice observations that
there are transient lipid droplet
lysosome interactions going on in the
hepatocytes so if i play this movie for
you of green lipid droplets and blue
lysosomes
you can see that the lysosomes are
kind of tickling around some of the
lipid droplets particularly the one at
the right interestingly the large one on
the left
they seem less interested in suggesting
that different lysosomes might have
different
types of uh interactions
or with lipid droplets
but ryan quantitated these and you can
see in the quantitation graph on the
left that most of these interactions are
ephemeral and short-lived
just uh
um seconds
but off to the far right of the graph
you can see there was a sub population
that some can last for two to four to
five minutes
suggesting that there was a longer
lasting interaction there
and so we were able to quantitate these
interactions
by making a chimeric
fluorescent reporter protein
and you can see in the cartoon there
at the very top of the cartoon there is
rfp tactic gfp
tagged to a lipid droplet protein
periolipin2
and so this will
decorate the outside of the lipid
droplets
and fluoresce yellow because there are
red and green
emittance
but once the lysosome bites off a piece
of the lipid droplet and in turn
integrates or internalizes this chimera
the acidic ph
will quench the uh
the green and you'll get red
and so you can see in this time series
at time zero there's a blue lysosome
that comes in
pinches off a piece
of the lipid droplet and then over time
you can see fluoresces red in the center
there
because it's internalized the reporter
which is now quenched the green and the
red emittance
predominates
so we can use this
to to measure
these types of interactions
and suggested that there is indeed
lysosomal lipid droplet direct
interactions so we wanted to look at
these by the electron microscope
and what we saw was kind of revealing
we saw
that if particularly when we starve
cells or just put them in
uh culture media without amino acids
and then fixed and looked at them
we could see lipid droplets that were
if you look at the upper left image you
can see that there's a phagolysis on
there
that's got all the dense staining
internalized membrane and part of the
lipid droplet is kind of being injected
into the lumen of the of the lysosome
the same down in the lower left
if you look at the larger micrograph on
the right you can see one lipid droplet
that's
or several that are being attacked by
multiple
lysosomes at the same time kind of
biting them off
again
not forming autophagosomes but appear to
be a direct lysosome
lipid droplet interaction
and we can quantitate these it took us a
lot of work to do
uh 20 to 30 cells under different
conditions and you can see
that when we start the cell that these
profiles and interactions are greatly
enhanced
they're hard to find under cells under
normal conditions
so
we then wanted to see if we could
actually observe an exchange of lipids
in live cells
and you can see that
based on the micrographs that i showed
you
we think that there's two kinds
there's an injection of lipid from the
lipid droplet down into the lysosome
but there's also this kind of biting and
breaking
of
the lysosome
and this one has this lipid droplet's
got four or five lysosomes all pulling
and yanking on it
and so i'm going to show you some videos
of life cells looking at
green bow dippy lipids
and
red lysosomes
i couldn't get the movies to play
like they're supposed to next to the ems
so
these are separate ones so here is
uh i put them on separate slides
on the left is a low mag of the cell
green lipid droplets and red lysosomes
and on the right is a zoom in
of uh this one on the on the lower
down at six o'clock
but if you look at the right you'll see
a high mag
of the red
lysosome and green lipid droplets and
i'll play this
the red
[Music]
see it was like i was like muted for a
second
um
hopefully you can still hear me
i'll play it again
this is the green lipid droplet
you can see that there's a change
in the spectral shift and it goes to
kind of a
muddy
whitish green
suggesting that there's transfer of the
lipid into the red lysosome
the next video is this bite phenomena
again looking at green lipid droplets
and red lice
see this red lysosome come in
and
take a
kind of an engulfment
of the of the lipid droplet and then the
lipid drop it looks like it disappears
so you can actually watch it
being catabolized i'll play it one more
time
there
so again two types one which the lipid
seems to be injected into the lumen of
the lysosome and another when the
lysosome actually either bites it off or
engulfs it whole
and so
we can test if this micro lava
lipophagic process actually utilizes
key components from other autophagic
mechanisms
and i think uh to
pick my pace up a little bit i won't
spend a lot of time on this only to tell
you that
the lipid can still get into the lumen
of lysosomes even when we inhibit
conventional autophagic proteins
so
as joel goodman from ut southwestern
highlighted this paper that we published
in pnes you wrote a nice commentary
called the importance of microlipophagy
as it's called in the liver
and this
phenomena of
microautophagy has been observed in
yeast for well over 10 years in which
the vacuole of the of the yeast which is
huge
uh can actually engulf
or directly uh eat
lipid droplets or other organelles
and so
in this three-dimensional reconstruction
through a hepatocyte you can see the
the red
uh
lipid droplet with little blue lysosome
going on and kind of pinching it off
in three dimensions
and so to summarize
microautophagy as it's called is the
predominant form of autophagy or
lipophagocytes it's not the exclusive
but certainly the predominant in the
hepatocyte it's independent of distinct
forms of macroautophagy or chaperone
media mediated autophagy
it's induced by low nutrient stress
and it's driven by direct
lipid droplet interactions with either a
late endosome or a lysosomal compartment
and so we're very interested on
the machinery that drives this
because if you look at
this em again that i'm showing you you
can see that
there's uh clearly a very definitive
docking of the lysosome and we think
that what's important here a mailing
address how to get these organelles
together a switch that's going to
stimulate this and some kind of
mechanochemical force
that might
exude the lipid droplet into the aqueous
environment of the endolysosome and off
to the right are some examples of this
of proteins that we think might mediate
these interactions
just to give you one taste of what we're
looking at though that's quite graphic
if you look at the left you'll see blue
lipid droplets
uh with green actin
and red lysosomes and you can see
under the lipid channel
in the next
image there that the lipid droplet is
protruding into
uh
the red lysosome and around that is kind
of a corona of actin
a stained by life act so there appears
to be an actin contractile mechanism
that
uh is
encompassing the exuding or extruding
lipid into the lysosome something that
we're currently pursuing
now in the in the last part of the talk
i wanted to cover some cytoskeletal
proteins that we've talked about uh 15
or 20 minutes ago
and their role
in mitochondrial dynamics
and this project was spearheaded by
hong and jing in the lab
and hong i worked together for a long
time
together
we helped identify
two different proteins that are involved
in
the fission of mitochondria which you
know are dynamic organelles they can be
long and tubular or they can be short
and vesicular
and it turns out that dynamic family
members these large gtp aces
mediate
these
fission and fusion events
we identified dynamin ii and the
mitochondrial specific dynamic-like
protein
back uh
20 years ago
as well as dynamic ii
other dynamic family members
such as mida fusion and oppa
actually will fuse mitochondria into
long tubules
but what were we asking
um well
is this dynamic
important
and it's been shown by many others that
yes it is that mitochondrial dynamics
can regulate
apoptosis or calcium signaling
autophagy pathways and so forth
but i want to focus on one
dynamic family member called mx
which stands for a mixo uh
protein
um
and
what's exciting about these dynamic
family members is that they're only
markedly related to dynamics maybe forty
percent
um but they're clearly part of the
family but they convey viral resistance
to mammalian cells
and
uh
there's two forms mxa and mxb
are focused on mxb which is known to
convey resistance to
hiv herpes simplex virus and also
hepatitis b
virus
and if you look at the image
that we took of hep 3b cells
that are expressing a gfp tagged mxb
it was well known that mxb is on the
outer nuclear envelope of cells
and in the cartoon people have
postulated that it perhaps
prevents
internalization of the viral capsid
uh of these infectious viruses into the
nucleus for transcription
that has been kind of the dogma of how
these work but you'll notice that in the
fluorescent micrograph there were
there's a lot of cytoplasmic staining
for mxb as well
so we try to figure out what this
staining is and what's
also interesting is that these mx
proteins
are
expressed on an interferon inducible
promoter
so
normally they're they're not highly
expressed in cells
until they're infected
which induces their expression
and so for example
you can see that we treated these cells
with interferon and that the mxb levels
in this western blot go up 10 fold
so this is a dynamic family member
conveys viral resistance
uh in cells and is uh
induced by interferon
we thought that was kind of exciting
um
although not worked by us work by others
but what is this cytosolic localization
seen
by immunofluorescence that i showed you
there in that picture
well the key observation was that it's
localized to the outer and inner
membranes of hepatocyte mitochondria
and so
you can see
these micrographs of hepatocytes stained
for either mxb or mxbgfp
down in the lower color pictures you can
see the mitochondria in red
with really a significant
co-localization of the mxv proteins on
the mitochondria
so we did this with a lot of different
constructs a lot of different antibodies
all suggesting it was on the
mitochondria but we also did perform
biochemistry and did subcellular
fractionation of pig hepatocytes and you
can see
if you look at the top of the mxb
um
that
as we enrich for mitochondria
are we enrich for mxb
you can see right below it is a cox-4
which has a big wad there under the pure
uh mitochondrial
column
showing that the mxb is significantly
enriched
so
okay there's this dynamic
that's interferon induced that's on
mitochondria does it change
mitochondrial morph morphology if we
alter the expression of mxb
so we did both si and short hairpin
knockdowns
in this image i'll show you that cells
expressing a gtpase defective mutant of
mxb
display a reduced staining of ender
christie
and you can see
that
if we look at mitochondria stained for
cox4
and mxb here's a cell that is
transfected we look at the dual staining
for the mitochondria marker and do you
see how
much dimmer the mitochondrial transport
cox4 staining is in the transfected cell
with the mutant mxb
compared to the surrounding cells
down in the lower right and left that
are quite bright so that confused us
until we went ahead and did some
electron microscopy to see if the
structure of these mitochondria were
altered in the mutant dynamic cells
and really we didn't expect to see this
but it blew us away
that
when you look at the mitochondria in
these cells so you and for example in
hela cells
you can see the mitochondria on the left
uh look very nice lots of interchristi
but if you look at the cells expressing
the mutant mxb in which the cox staining
went away
you can see that the mitochondria are
almost hollow
and so the cells or the mitochondria
lose their christie which is the reason
that they're not staining they don't
have anything to stain
so this provided us with a nice
functional correlation to the
localization that this protein was
somehow involved in
mitochondrial christian dynamics
so we asked if these mitochondria are
functionally disrupted
you might expect that these mitochondria
would not be able to maintain an
electron proton gradient
and yes we found that if we
stain cells
with a rhodamine one two three die
that
the membrane potential these
mitochondria are lost
so this is a dye that is incorporated
into mitochondria based on the proton
gradient
and we can under control cells just
express
a cherry vector which are in cells there
and you can see down below that the
rhodamine one two three all the cells
have brightly stained mitochondria
because they've taken up the dye
but off to the right in the right column
is the mxv gtp ace mutant and you can
see two or three cells there with the
asterisks that have been transfected
with a mutant and then if you go down
below and look at the rhodamine channel
with the asterisks you can see the cells
are dark
so these cells uh are unable
to have mitochondria that can
intercalate this dye suggesting that
they're dysfunctional and so we looked
at a lot of cells under different
experiments and you can see the
quantitation on the right
showing the difference in
in the activity of the mitochondria
so finally we asked if manipulation of
mxb
leads to a loss of mitochondrial
nucleoids
what are these nucleoids
many of you might know
that
mitochondria have their own genome
assuming
that this was when they were independent
organisms back millions of years ago
and the nucleoids or the mitochondrial
genome encodes for 37 genes
most of them are for trnas but 13 are
for proteins
and uh we asked
i mean it was no it's known that
mitochondrial dynamics can
alter the genome of mitochondria
and so what we did was to uh as you can
see in the image here express either
vector alone
or knock down mxb with
short hair pins
or express the mutant k40 or
the
k to a mutant
in the mx
and
what i hope you can see that in the
controls
that the green nucleoids so we're just
staying for dna which will stain
the
nuclear dna as well as the mitochondrion
nucleoids you can see the red
mitochondria
with these kind of cute little green
uh nuclear stains superimposed on them
but off to the right
if you look at the cells in which
the mxp has been disrupted
you'll see that not only are the
mitochondrial fragmented like i showed
you before
but that the nucleoids are pretty much
in the cytoplasm
that there's some co-localization but
not nearly as much
and so the quantitation down below
shows
uh first the percent of
green mitochondrial spots that
superimpose
over
the red mitochondria
and
or do not superimpose so
you can see that as the number goes up
there's more and more
green dots that are in the cytoplasm and
not
overlapping with the red mitochondria
on the right we can do pcr
for cytoplasmic
mitochondrial dna
and you can see that
this is significantly changed as well
by the cytoplasmic mitochondrial dna
copy number
which is markedly increased when we
knock down
mxb
so
it appears
that
altering
mxb levels and cells results in a
fragmentation of the mitochondrial
genome with an increase
of mitochondrial dna something that we
don't really understand
so why are we excited about this study
it's a dynamic protein that's induced
by viral infection
based on interferon levels in the cell
and
we didn't know much about
uh mitochondrial and innate immune
responses
but uh we've been reading heavily on
this
by these reviews uh
uh published by uh sankaragosh and his
his colleagues
and indeed
it appears
that
this is the last slide that i'll be
showing you
um
that mitochondria will
release
their their genomes
in response to either bacterial or viral
infections
so
the cell can sense
when prokaryotic genomes are released in
the cytoplasm via this sea gas
pathway
and you can see uh by the cartoon it's
not our cartoons it's from riley and
tate
that
not only does the
invasive virus induce uh sea gas
activation but it's potentiated by then
release of the mitochondrial genomes
and so this can then lead to
the sting pathway
and
activate transcription factors which
will increase type 1 interferon and
potentiate the
innate immune response
so we're quite excited about
uh this as a novel pathway
and a new function for this mxv protein
and how it might convey viral resistance
to these
viruses that plague us
so those are the three areas that i
wanted to talk to you about this is the
group that has done all the work on a
sunny day in
minnesota
before the pandemic these are our
funding sources
and
[Music]
during the pandemic people moved on
to other locations
um some
did post-docs at good places like dana
farber and university of north carolina
some have gotten started their own
faculty positions at university of
nebraska or gone to the to the private
sector cytotherax
um and someone started graduate school
so
i'm
proud of this group it's also my way of
telling you that
why it was hard to hire during the
pandemic that we do have positions if
any of these
areas of study
are are of interest to you
and i appreciate your attention and
thanks for having me
and thank you dr mcmahon for that
wonderful presentation we will now start
the live q and a portion of our webinar
and if you have any questions you'd like
to ask please do so now just click on
that ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen so let's get
started we already have some great
questions coming in from our audience
our first question
um how do you think the lipid droplets
dock with
the lysosome
yeah thanks for that we're
we're pretty interested in that
and you might remember one slide that i
showed that had the mail a postal
mailing address of how to get those
together
[Music]
and
we we think that it's it's a biophysical
problem because
you have this monolayer
of phospholipids around a very
hydrophobic
triglyceride content
with
a lysosome with a bilayer
with an aqueous
inside
and somehow those two are going to need
to get together and fuse
and open up
to have one envelop the other
so how is that going to happen
i showed you one piece of data
implicating the actin cytoskeleton so
we think that
there could actually be a contractile
apparatus perhaps of myosins or
or dynamins or other contractile
proteins
that are recruited
via the actin cytoskeleton to kind of
squeeze
and
compress the two organelles together
but that's something that we're uh we're
very interested in
studying
thank you so much with one more question
coming in
is the mx protein on the inner
mitochondrial membrane and how might it
enter the mitochondria
yeah so i i went through that really
fast
um
what we did and these were these type of
experiments were were designed by
blober global and vaulter over 40 years
ago
of
you blot the organelle for your protein
of interest
and yeah okay so
mx is on the mitochondria it's enriched
in the mitochondria
but what happens if you add trypsin to
the mitochondria first
does it reduce the amount of mx protein
by proteolyzing it
and it does so uh to about half of it
but not all of it
and so
uh
when we do that experiment
and then include triton to allow the
trypsin to get in it degrades the rest
of it so it appears that the mx protein
is both in and on
uh the mitochondria and
how it's targeted to the mitochondria is
something that we've just been studying
we actually think we've identified a 20
amino acid sequence in the in the center
of mx that provides a essentially a
target signal
uh or a signal sequence
for uh integration of the mx protein
inside inside the mitochondria so we're
kind of excited about that
um
[Music]
thank you so much dr mcniven would you
like to provide any closing remarks
before we go today
no i think
i appreciate
people listening and i hope it was clear
and uh please send me emails or call me
if you have any questions or
would like to interact in any way i
appreciate your your time
well we appreciate your time dr mcniven
and thank you again for your important
research and your presentation today and
before we go i also want to thank our
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions and
questions we did not have time for and
those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by our speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
and this webcast can be viewed on demand
for two years until september 2023
libraries will alert you via email when
it's available for replay and we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time take
care everyone and be safe bye
thank you